senora kennedy my spanish teacher  flat out knew i was gonna rule the world  like just she did she gave me d's  she called my mom once and said look i'm  giving him d's because if he doesn't  pass language in new jersey he can't  graduate and he already failed german  freshman sophomore year so he needs to  get by my class but i think he's going  to be okay as i started getting my early  success in the wine business front page  of the star ledger and new york times  localized stuff she would always send me  a letter to the store and i would always  call her and invite her to the store and  walk around and give her wine she's my  person she really means a lot to me  because it was the only grown-up  really outside of my mom  that i think really  knew that i was going to the moon  [Music]